au carrefour du parc industriel de
bécancour dans le centre du québec se
trouve un petit diamant vert le géant
français air liquide il y a inauguré il
ya moins d'un an la première usine dans
le monde à produire à grande échelle de
l'hydrogène faire grâce à l'électrolysé
de l'eau
vous avez là en face de vous c'est
l'arrivée de la puissance électrique
donc hydro québec nous fournit une
électricité renouvelable et donc bas
carbone
[Musique]
notre élément essentiel ce que vous avez
ici donc c'est l'eau alors l'eau vous
voyez d'ailleurs dans ce réservoir est
une eau industrielle ultra purs on est
donc prêt dans une deuxième étape à
aller vers les électrolyseurs et à
séparer a cassé cette molécule d'eau
avec le courant électrique
et les membranes qui sont dans cet
empilement ont une perméabilité qui est
différentiel à la molécule d'eau est
allé aux molécules d'hydrogène ce qui
veut dire que d'un côté de la membrane
on va garder l'oxygène et de l'autre on
va trouver l'hydrogène c'est comme ça
qu'on laissait par l'hydrogène il va
partir sur ce rac se palpent la sfio et
on va l'amener progressivement au niveau
de ce qu'on appelle le liquéfacteur on
prend l'hydrogène gazeux comme dans un
frigo mais en beaucoup plus froid on va
passer d'un hydrogène comprimé un
hydrogène liquéfié air liquide produit
tonnes d'hydrogène verres par jour ça
représente le tiers de la production le
reste étant produit avec du gaz naturel
l'électro lise côte deux à trois fois
plus cher que le procédé par
hydrocarbures le prix de vente est donc
aussi plus élevé pour rendre le précieux
gaz attrayant il faudra augmenter la
production cette course à la taille
c'est pas pour la beauté de faire gros
c'est pour diminuer les coûts répondre
également à une demande qu'on voit
croissante
la minière australienne fortescue est
l'un des géants industriels de la
planète qui est à la recherche
d'hydrogène vers
la région de la côte-nord et ses
barrages hydroélectriques sont dans la
mire de l'entreprise explique la
présidente et chef de la direction
l'objectif de l'entreprise et d'avoir
son propre site de production d'ici
trois à cinq ans mais le québec n'est
pas seul dans la course pour le
titre nous avons visité 60 pays en 18
mois on ira vite de l'avant dans
l'endroit où on obtiendra rapidement les
autorisations gouvernementales et
l'appui de la communauté explique la
femme d'affaires on a tout les atouts
assurons-nous de wallonie vers le feu
vert viendra-t-il du québec le ministre
des ressources naturelles et convaincu
de vouloir se lancer dans l'aventuré de
l'hydrogène vert mais à quel prix pour
le moment la production est coûteuse et
énergivore la production d'une tonne
d'hydrogène vert coûte 2400 $ en frais
d'électricité
les coûts sont assez élevés
par rapport à l'électricité convoi y
injecter et si on saute pas aujourd'hui
d'entrain en 2030 qu'elle va plus de
résultats il va être trop tard pour le
gouvernement déposera sa stratégie
chiffrer à plusieurs milliards de
dollars au printemps on est surpris
qu'un avenir pour lui dont gilbert au
québec mais aux propos on viendra pas
brader notre énergie à tout prix la
question n'est donc plus de savoir si le
québec entrera dans la course mais à
quelles conditions
et si valérie gamache radio canada
bécancour